oui c'est vrai que c'était à deux trois
ans voilà j'ai rencontré un garçon il
m'a invité à voir le foot bon déjà je
suis pas fan du foot mais j'ai dit ok je
vais faire un métier un peu fan de foot
un moment absolument pas je fais un
effort je vois rien d'autre avec un jour
là allez allez aaa mais non mais pas une
phase aller avec deux greffes quoi
l'atelier vous ça va a annoncé que sa
fille était passionné par le foot bref
on s'en fout et même du coup au final
j'y suis allé j'ai fait un effort j'ai
pu voir la personne
ouais je l'installé tout il enlève ses
chaussures et là je me dis mais c'est
pas possible mais ça sent les poubelles
ça sent le fromage les poubelles je dis
non c'est pas possible
bon je regarde quand même le match je
prends sur moi et le lendemain je
retourne le voir et appareils la même
chose il relève si je suis pas le mec en
plus il voulait absolument le message
sur le kabyle plus des pieds c'est pas
une mais des bottes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu le sais tu verras en bosnie mais des
après-ski annoncions bas mais le calme
absolu manqué c'est comme les gars qui
peut de la gale et veulent absolument
vous dire mes secrets
[Applaudissements]
donc au final je me suis dit c'est plus
possible donc j'ai tenu la soirée parce
que c'est quelqu'un de poli et je n'ai
pas dit mais alors moi je vais envoyer
un message et lui dit c'est pas possible
tu peux dire honnêtement je vais pas du
genre non je lui ai dit j'ai des
problèmes avec l'hygiène voilà c'est
enfin si je lui ai dit avant mais ça
peut s'arranger depuis oui je sais que
les gens qui aient pu dominer pu plus is
les laves puis puis les pieds morales a
fait une étude elle a jeté l'argent
le ghana j'aurais leur entrée alors et
messieurs luc wéry excuse moi je vais
pas les laver parce que ça va encore
plus plus et ça a le mérite en étant
brunissent macquarie je savais déjà bas
en tout cas bravo belle enquête